[Applaudissements]
18 minutes
pas le temps du puisque je vous faire là
par contre avant chaque conférence
j'aime bien faire un petit peu Daphné
Daphné se retire ta respiration ralentir
son rythme cardiaque et se détendre en
plus à l'aise dans adéquation avec son
environnement est un sport qui moi me
passionne et j'ai commencé très jeune
parce que j'avais un peu près 7,8 ans il
y a une vingtaine d'années que j'adorais
faire et qu'il faisait beaucoup beaucoup
ma famille et surtout ma grand-mère est
mouillé disparaître dans l'eau relire
plusieurs minutes après après avoir créé
mon nom des centaines de fois sur la
plage
mais c'est pas la seule passion que
j'avais quand j'étais petit et une autre
petite passion qu'on a sûrement tout ce
qu'on a tous eu quand on était jeune les
châteaux de sable
on va dire qu'aujourd'hui j'ai 8 ans on
va dire qu'aujourd'hui on a tous les
temps
sur la plage on fait notre notre petit
château de sable
et là petit chat total pour nous c'est
le plus beau le plus grand le plus beau
kilomètres jusqu'au bout de la plage on
en est extrêmement fier
can you see me dit que c'est plus beau
des châteaux de sable
c'est bon ça c'est un souvenir un peu
flou parce qu'au final mon château de
sable il ressemblait un peu plus à ça
donc donc c'est pas la taille qui compte
j'avais une petite particularité c'est
que je savais comment faire pour que mon
château de sable soit le plus beau et se
démarquer parmi tous les autres
n'étaient pas incroyable mais il y avait
un petit plus parce que j'avais rajouté
deux belles bouteilles en plastique pour
faire l'entrée du château
je vais rajouter et sac plastique dans
les douze pour que l'on reste bien ça
passe des pelles de bien me menaçant tu
récupères un deuxième sac plastique j'ai
raccroché un poteau
planter dans le sable pour faire une
sorte de drapeau
et j'ai récupéré plein de petit bouchon
bouteille plastique capsules de bière
que j'avais mis sur les tours qui brille
au soleil
j'en étais extrêmement fier de mon
château
et en voyant cette photo de moi petit
côté de ce magnifique château je me
disais peut-être un problème
j'ai d'autres souvenirs qui reviennent
les souvenirs de l'appeler justement
quand j'allais plonger sous l'eau
balader parmi les poissons
les coraux c'est en Bretagne et qu'on a
pas attendre que ça là-bas mais je
voyais comme des belles choses et méduse
dangereuse mais tellement belle qui
brille comme ça un peu transparente
est-ce que c'était vraiment des méduses
que je voyais
c'est encore un souvenir fou d'autres
choses
ouvrir la
ils sont ils sont revenus ils m'ont fait
prendre conscience d'une chose il y
avait une urgence il y avait un besoin
et que peut-être
avec mon énergie mon ambition est la
bonne volonté j'allais pouvoir agir pour
ça alors j'ai fait des études
lycée
les amis on s'amuse on sort et on
travaille
il travaille moi je suis souvent au fond
de la classe
va dormir ou juste pas là j'ai du mal
avec l'école j'ai beaucoup de mal avec
l'école l'autorité les profs
devoir et contrôle le par cœur j'ai du
mal avec ça me passionne pas vraiment et
ça se ressent
un peu pour ça on met un peu la pression
mais essaie de rester fidèle à moi-même
j'ai mes passions à côté j'apprends ce
que j'ai envie d'apprendre mais je
m'accroche quand même si j'arrive en
étude supérieur et alors c'est quoi le
Graal on était supérieur et grandes
écoles les écoles de commerce
Polytechnique et autres
alors j'arrive en école supérieure
j'arrive à l'école des métiers de
l'environnement une école d'ingénieur
spécialisé en environnement pour moi
c'était une fierté génial arrivé dans
une école en école j'avais étudié
comment agir pour toucher le plus
l'océan
et non la même chose le même schéma
j'ai toujours du mal avec les cours j'ai
toujours du mal avec le programme j'ai
toujours du mal avec l'autorité
pas vraiment que je suis mauvais c'est
juste que je ne suis pas à ma place mais
ça ça je le sais pas encore
qu'est-ce que je suis dans cette école
dans cette école moi Adrien qui suis une
personne physique en chair et en os
dans cette école je suis une
juste une note
dans une ligne sur un tableau Excel un
petit chiffre sur une feuille de copie
en petit chiffre sur un carnet de notes
je suis une note et comme les notes ne
sont pas très bonne dans cette école
je suis personne parce qu'on ne me
considère pas parce que mes notes sont
pas bonnes alors je n'arrive pas à rien
je n'aurais pas d'avenir je suis pas à
ma place il faut que je m'accroche faut
que je travaille faut que je fasse comme
les autres
je veux sauver l'océan très bien
commence par avoir des bonnes notes
j'arrive pas à ça ne me correspond pas
je suis pas à l'aise avec ce milieu là
mais je m'accroche je m'accroche et
alors c'est quoi l'autre excellente
après l'école et le monde de
l'entreprise intégrer une grosse
multinationale
quand même
et j'arrive dans une grosse
multinationale
en allemand
Hadrien Collot
responsable environnement France
une note
incroyable incroyable parce que dans ces
entreprises ont de faire
ce genre de département mais au final
bloquer les actionnaires derrière et
l'environnement ça me rapporte rien
j'ai entendu des dizaines des centaines
des milliers de fois l'environnement ça
ne rapporte rien
c'est pas vraiment quelque chose qui
permet de quantifier l'argent que ma
rentrée derrière c'est pas parce que je
vais sauver une tortue que derrière elle
va acheter mes produits et que je vais
pouvoir payer le salaire de mes employés
et le mien au passage
très bien alors j'arrête tout
j'arrête tout je termine mes études je
vais à la banque et je leur dis c'est un
projet
je vais monter le mien le projet de ma
vie découvre l'entrepreneuriat
le monde merveilleux où on crée son
projet on crée sa start-up son
entreprise on devient de maître de sa
vie
recrue et on a des bureaux on choisit
ses problèmes c'est ça la liberté au
final
ne plus avoir de problème après la
personne la plus riche du monde a
beaucoup de problèmes
la liberté c'est de choisir ses
problèmes
dans ce monde-là je sens que cette fois
c'est pouvoir faire ce que je veux
choisir les problèmes que je dois
frotter toujours ce même problème de
pollution dans l'océan
alors je me lance et je crée new
première start-up et crème solaire
écologique minérale engagé transparente
on est elle est proche du consommateur
on essaie de développer les meilleurs
produits possible on est complètement
transparent sur le composition mes
nouveaux problèmes on nous dit oui mais
et comment on fait pour se reconnaître
dans ce monde-là
la publicité du marketing du
référencement des influenceurs
il faut l'argent il faut du budget 10 20
30 40 50 pour 100 du budget d'une
start-up
arrête de la communication et du
marketing
j'ai du mal du mal parce que tu es une
belle femme blonde maillot de bain
aller 25 route au maximum sur la plage
les cheveux au vent à grand sourire qui
s'arrête qui met sa crème U
équivalence la belle phrase avec nous au
jeu
pas mal pas mal
non
non là je me dis j'ai une autre idée à
risque un coup de poker et choses que
jamais personne à fait
mais moi j'ai envie de faire tout cet
argent là qu'on met dans le marketing et
dans la communication je vais le prendre
je vais l'utiliser et je vais l'injecter
dans des actions environnementales je
vais enfin pouvoir faire ce que j'ai
envie de faire tout le monde me dit mais
non
la planète mais pas les factures les
employés ça
on va
aller sur le terrain
14 pl McRae
avec ses consommateurs avec ses amis
avec son équipe et montrer que nous on
s'est investi vraiment prendre de notre
temps prend de notre énergie prendre de
notre argent pour ça et au fait on le
fait avec un projet
un produit acheter un mètre carré de
placo nettoyer
lance ta et aussi bon
jamais ça marche très compliqué donc on
prend de l'avance avant même de lancer
la start-up on commence à nettoyer des
plages des événements ramène des
bénévoles ramène au début c'était une
personne la plus proche mais
des associations
à faire des pollution plage
et des sacs de l'ampleur du problème et
on fait découvrir aux autres
la sélection
on se retrouve trop sur la scène
médiatique comme la start-up engagé
on nous appelle
où est-ce que je peux acheter vos
produits que je peux les trouver comment
je fais pour vous dire que moi ce que je
fais pour vous aider de personne nous
appelle j'ai un magasin j'aimerais
prendre vos produits parce que
l'histoire me plaît j'ai envie de
raconter cette histoire la mission
peut-être la composition des produits
l'histoire je veux vos produits parce
que je veux votre histoire
aujourd'hui on doit avoir 300 410d
pendant au moins 12 ans pharmacie plus
de l'export de l'international tout est
parti de là on a dû des marchés
peut-être 10 ou 20 pourcents de tous à
tous les autres sont jaloux parce qu'ils
ont aimé cette histoire ils ont ils ont
aimé ce projet
on l'a raté mais parlera partager nos
valeurs
c'est pas tout
c'est pas tout parce que se retrouver
avec beaucoup de demandes aussi de
bénévolat deux personnes qui voulait
s'engager avec nous et tu vas les
trouver une solution pour ça
pourquoi nettoyer les plages
beaucoup et on a commencé à les nettoyer
avec des personnes de plus en plus connu
plus de méga
par exemple à Marseille à Marseille avec
une association partenaire qu'on adore
qui s'appelle Keen'V calanques on a pu
faire beaucoup de dépollution dans les
calanques de Marseille sur les plages de
Marseille jusqu'à le faire avec
enjoyPhoenix une influenceuse une
youtubeuse la plus grande youtubeuse
française qui est venu avec nous
nettoyer jusqu'au fond de rempli de
vieilles batteries de bidon d'huile de
bouteille je ne sais quoi tu es venu
avec nous mettre les malades dans
on a eu cette moto
gratuitement gratuitement
parce qu'on a fait pour de vrai parce
que c'était vraiment nos valeurs parce
que c'est vraiment si on croyait que
c'était sur
tous les médias tous les gens t'ont
parlé de nous on commence à y croire
aussi
et là on a eu un nouveau problème
on est l'entreprise en étagères des
alternants des employés c'est bien mais
des bénévoles
attention
alors on a créé Octopus
on a fondé à côté de la start-up avec
une équipe dédiée
avec des membres à part entière de
projet là j'avais fondé New avec
Corentin un ami d'enfance
on a fondé on peut plus avec Lola notre
ami d'enfance passionné aussi par
l'humanitaire et par l'environnement qui
a pris la tête de cette organisation là
maintenant c'est à part d'épaule les
personnes qui travaillent à plein-temps
sur les nouveaux projets qu'on développe
comme par exemple au-delà des messages
de plage la dépollution hydrocarbures
avec des boudin absorbant à base de
cheveux avec les stars
partenaire du projet
qui permet d'absorber jusqu'à 8 fois on
était notamment partenaire de la marée
noire à l'île Maurice il y a un peu près
un an ou le
plein de nouveaux projets des nouvelles
technologies aussi pour ça
qu'on est en train de perdre 50 % du
corps et qui meurt à travers le monde
alors on a décidé d'agir maintenant on
est à la tête de nos propres projets de
replantation 2 € en retrait de la
biodiversité aurais un plan du corail
donc il y a des espèces menacées aux
disparus de revenir dernièrement sur ce
projet pilote qu'on a pu créer notamment
graisse des hippocampes qui avait
disparu depuis 10 ans dans la région
pour nous c'est une fierté énorme énorme
pourquoi parce qu'on a refusé de payer
cette fameuse pub avec cette petite
blonde qui pourrait sur la plage
non
et après ça
avec un nouveau projet qu'on a monté
rien à voir les boissons énergisantes
alcoolisé et naturel un peu le même
console que new mets sur la plus festive
mais toujours avec le même engagement
est réellement sur le terrain est
réellement dans l'action et agir agir
agir
pour l'environnement pour la planète
toujours et toujours y aller ça fait 3
ans qu'on travaille sur ce projet
il y a pas un mois on va pas aller
dépolluer avec le bénévole y a pas un
mois on va pas essaie de voyager pour
aller rencontrer des nouveaux
partenaires il y a pas un bon on va pas
les financer des nouveaux projets lancer
des nouvelles initiatives
alors qu'est-ce que ça ne va pas
concrètement énormément de choses je
voulais dire avant des nouveaux
distributeur des clients des gens qui
viennent demain vers nous
et aussi quelque chose extrêmement
important quand on se lance le droit à
l'erreur le client le distributeur ne
partenaire tous tous été extrêmement
conciliant on a commencé avec des
produits avec un packaging en plastique
pour des raisons économiques qu'on a
très vite changer pour des packagings en
aluminium plus écologique mais quand les
gens me critiquer sur les réseaux et que
je prenais mon ordinateur paniquer à
dire à mon dieu mais qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette marque c'est du plastique
c'est du phishing avant même que
j'arrive à taper ma réponse quelqu'un
que tu
avais déjà répondu pour dire
laisse-les tranquille
regarde ce qu'ils font regarde à quel
point ils sont vraiment engagé la chance
parce que c'est sûr qu'ils vont servir
les personnes comme ça c'est sûr
on a droit à l'erreur et ça c'est plus
beau des cadeaux qu'on a vu avec ce
projet
l'environnement et un merveilleux moyen
de faire connaître un merveille au Moyen
de rentabiliser son projet à merveille
au Moyen de transformer des clients en
ambassadeur ambassadeur nous on adore on
parle
ces projets nous rapporter une dimension
environnementale humaine
dimensions que nous on n'aurait jamais
pu imaginer dès le début du projet pour
nous ça allait tomber au bout de 6 mois
6 mois pour tout le monde
de tonnes et des tonnes de déchets qu'on
a pu ramasser
je t'ai encore mais rien alors actuelle
les mégots
les mégots cette photo j'ai encore 8 ans
j'ai encore 8 ans parce que je joue
encore au milieu des déchets sur une
plage
les châteaux de sable maintenant je sais
les châteaux de bouteilles avec les
centaines de centaines de bouteilles
qu'on ramasse
ce sourire il est sincère et honnête ce
soir elle est juste heureux de tenir
60.000 mégots dans ta main quinzaine de
kg comme on a pu ramasser on appelle une
heure
et ce sourire il est juste
représentatif de tous parcours
c'est tout ce que j'ai entrepris de tout
ce que j'ai défendu
le petit dernier au fond de la classe
élèves qui avance
adresse qu'on pousse à pour dire non on
peut vraiment agir la solution qu'on m'a
donné elle me plaît pas le parcours
commun ce qui me plaît pas
et sortir de cadre là je vais agir
pendant même
et aujourd'hui il y a pas que des
Entrepreneurs dans la salle sinon
regarde
choisis un message pour vous
entrepreneur si vous avez pas forcément
l'ambition monter votre part vous
entreprenez quand même vous voulez man
vous lever le matin ou choisissez
comment vous allez vous habiller vous
faites ce que vous avez mangé vous avez
choisi les choisir un cadeau pour votre
famille pour vos amis
vous allez partir
j'avais entrepris quelque chose
si vous êtes entrepreneur vous pouvez
prendre du temps pour ça pas juste
rester dans ce cadre étude travail
métro-boulot-dodo retraite à la tu peux
profiter pour prendre un peu de temps
pour vous engager dans une cause
défendre quelque chose
vous apportera toujours toujours quelque
chose en plus
de passer chercher dans vos valeurs que
j'ai dans le souvenir
engagé vous
et vous aussi vous serez à ce petit
enfant de 8 ans qui jouent parmi les
déchets non plus dans la conscience mais
bien dans la conscience dans la vie
d'agir
avec tout blanc maison du monde de faire
changer les choses
[Applaudissements]